символ n 41 секунда
c єдиний widow пізніше джек прямий ще не
інтеру що вдалося знайти вати і стріть
ти 6 комерс посторожу не оствер читала
канал чому веду він іноді ви
правоохоронцям ранку за те хто ті люди
звук на газ на камені кіно чук топить підлогу
лабуде blue ваги в цьому відмінність на
контроль особі справа думають малюка в
україні червоною у не ми чинимо з 5-ти до
smart наш найкраще ще можна розрубати
тему конкретного випуску центри мати
висоті свободу слова the rescue за суд 2
тис вона з пропаганду і точно не боретеся
з лихом насильства у team я боюся цих
актів чини в під не переслідувати йому
це на лижним чином likely to some зму
репортером би в кургані до дієту і
факт що багата справ диво напади на
журналісті в Україні до сина розкрив і
про крин то ось на вселяючи довели позиція
міністра внутрішніх страх України та
таємно за родом дні заявивши українським ЗМІ
що такі канали та enter пробує
владний народ на таких чонко
це дуже фатальний постріл міністра там
навчали всіх тайсонів та садівниками мавлани
метро ти абсолютно не ви правда війна
під нього президент даулет україни
заслуговує nap 1 канал що поважаються
провокації та
oleg че праворуч знайду видають до кінця
ситуація зі свободою слова у краї не
може втішника самий вид суть несе
і дальності за зло чини проти
журналістів то олігархічний вплив на
медіа тягнути україну вниз світловим
рейтингу репортерів без кордонів